Kim Kardashian's security team tackled  Kris Jenner wait what wait my security  apparently so  in a new teaser for Sunday night's  Keeping Up with the Kardashians we see  Kim answering a frantic phone call from  Khloe after the apparent incident  occurred I'm rushing home right now but  what happens never a dull moment you can  hear Kris in the background in what  seems like a lot of pain after the  altercation with the security team you  do see how it actually unfolded and what  happened because everybody thinks they  know the whole story and they don't it's  unknown if Kris suffered any serious  injuries from the tackle but in a promo  for the season we did see Kris in a  stretcher was it a case of mistaken  identity  we'll have to tune into Sunday's episode  to find out because you never know  what's gonna happen